just go with me on this okay don't talk
to me just go with me okay
show me what happens if the temperature
of that is absolute zero
thank you it can't be i know but there
we go now show me what happens
if that is
lukewarm
all right no
now
show me what happens if that is very hot
now
show me what happens if that is a
negative temperature it has
you can't do it
this is my potential energy surface no
what is it really it's two chairs
with a blanket over the top the blankets
the blanket the dog sleeps on when i
bring the dog into the office we have a
miniature dachshund um never ever ever
ever anybody out there ever get a
miniature dachshund to the most
disobedient dog on the face of the
planet so we are talking about negative
temperatures we really are somewhere
behind the cutting edge i guess in terms
of describing this brady wanted to do at
the beginning of january i wanted to do
it at the beginning of january brady's
been away i've been away and
unfortunately we only get around to it
now first and most importantly it's
beautiful work absolutely stunning work
and we'll talk about that all of your
oreos about this excellent paper
negative absolute temperature from
emotional degrees of freedom
but negative absolute temperatures are
not
a new thing this was 1956.
so this has been known about for quite
some time and in effect
every time you use a laser pointer
you're exploiting negative temperatures
well of course we're not talking about
just minus so many celsius on you know
minus fahrenheit we're of course talking
about the absolute temperature scale
we're talking about zero kelvin
where if we could get there in the third
law of thermodynamics and quantum
mechanics tells us we can't if we could
get there all motion would stop
so we're talking about negative
temperatures
apparently temperatures the other side
of that
which you then might go but how can you
go beyond having no motion at all that
just makes no sense it's all about
how you actually define temperature and
now at this point
i don't want to disgruntle the physics
undergraduates and postgraduates out
there but i'm not going to lapse into a
discussion of entropy and the
relationship of temperature and entropy
we could do it that way but i'm going to
do it in a slightly different way for
those people who
like myself whose head starts to hurt
when you start thinking about entropy in
too much detail i'm going to talk about
distributions
we know now let's just shake these up
atoms in a box
let's close the box so they don't go
everywhere atoms and molecules in a box
basically the higher the temperature the
more the jiggling about that's that's
the general idea in terms of the
sort of layman's concept or whatever you
want to call in temperature it's more
important though to think about the
distribution of speeds indeed the
distribution of velocities
that's one of the most fundamental
aspects of temperature or am i allowed
to draw a graph one graph i promise just
one graph what we have
is on this axis
we have
the
molecular speed we're going to call that
v
and on this axis we have the probability
of finding a molecule
with a certain speed or finding
molecules within a certain range of
speeds
and what we have what we find
is we've got a curve that looks like
that
right
which is
as you can see asymmetric and it's got a
peak and if we heat
the molecules up then what we find is
that that curve
moves
and it also flattens
so what we find as you might expect if
you heat it up you get more molecules
there's a bigger there's a probability
now a bigger probability of finding more
molecules with faster speeds what's
important is it's not a single number
you can see it's a distribution that's
really really important
okay
so we got to get this concept of energy
levels in our heads before we we can go
any further with this so i'm proofed i'm
knackered um i'm so unfit right so what
we're going to what to be able to
explain negative temperatures i need to
move away from this type of you know
continuous distribution where we've got
millions and billions and gazillions of
different speeds here
and to think about
just a simple two level system where our
atoms and molecules can have one of two
energies
so they can be in what's called a low
energy state
or
in a high energy state
right
very straightforward
what they
generally want to do
if we leave negative temperatures to one
side we're talking about positive
temperatures
usual everyday things is what happens is
that the atoms and molecules
want to
occupy the lowest energy state that's
where you find the greatest probability
of finding them here we've got lots and
lots in the lowest energy state that's
in the high energy state am i allowed an
equation as well i've got the graph part
oh now you're pushing it just one
equation okay right and the way we
describe this
we just we work out the probability of
finding the atoms or molecules in those
it's a really simple equation due to
boltzmann and the probability
p let's call it is proportional to
ready for this
e
to the power
of minus we're going to call it delta e
over kt right before you balk at that so
that e stands for exponential
or maybe i'll just to be entirely clear
what we have is that
so that's this is called a boltzmann
factor
now let's just do some of the sums let's
plug some of the numbers in and what we
well first of all let me explain this
exponential we know what that is
delta e
is the difference i've only got two
energy levels but is the difference
between this energy level and this or
this energy level and this one oh this
one and this one all right
k is boltzmann's constant
and t is temperature and what's very
important here boltzmann's constant
allows us to convert between energy and
temperature so this is energy and this
this also when you multiply boltzmann's
constant by temperature it gives you an
energy okay
good got an equation on a graph i'm very
proud
whether it makes the final cut so note
if you go to a very high energy level
that's e to the minus something which
means that as you go up this ladder
as you go up this ladder it gets smaller
and smaller and smaller the
probabilities get smaller and smaller
and smaller happy
if you can engineer a system
whereby
this hat owns
whereby you have
very many more atoms and molecules in
the higher energy level than in the
lower energy and you keep going up
so you have more molecules then what
that means is that
we've got
the probability of finding the atoms and
molecules in a particular energy level
is proportional to the exponential and
minus delta over kt
right so we can look at that if we if we
change the energy level if we make this
larger
so if we go from
that level to that level to the higher
level then this value becomes bigger and
we've got e to the minus something which
is quite big which means that the
probability is quite small
however
what we can also do is we think about
this in terms of negative temperatures
make that t
negative
negative and negative cancel out
effectively and what we have
is that and now this is very interesting
as you go up the ladder as you go up
those those various energy states what
you find is that as this delta e is big
growing then this is going up so the
probability of finding the molecules up
here
is now greater
you see and that's that's where the
fundamental essence of this minus
temperature comes in because it's like
you had you've just taken that
distribution
and if you consider that what you have
now is an is a minus temperature
what a minus temperature gives you what
a negative temperature gives you is this
change in the distribution
it feels to me like
negative temperatures don't exist you've
just found a flaw in the equation no
it's not a floating equation it's it's
it's absolutely valid to do it this way
um but the very interesting thing here
is that this negative temperature
is greater than any positive temperature
right because if you take another object
and you bring it to this negative
temperature object
heat will flow energy will flow from the
negative temperature object
regardless of the temperature of the
other one regardless of the true
temperature of the other it will flow
that way if we've got
balls let's go back to balls
the top of a hill
we know that up there they've got quite
a large potential energy
what they really want to do see if you
just nudge them
sorry wrong side brady
let's do that
what we're effectively doing
is
we've got a negative temperature instead
of
the molecules being down there
by engineering a negative temperature
what you're doing is you're making it
preferable for the molecules to stay up
there what it's equivalent to is get one
of the pyramids which is like this and
flipping it around and getting it to
stand and it's it's it's head and the
way you do that
is why
where's the paper gone it's why that
particular paper is in science because
it's a
tour de force of experiments what they
do is they combine what's called an atom
trap
with
an optical lattice so they have atoms at
incredibly cold
temperatures
and um they use interfering beams of
light to trap those and to modify
the potential energy surface so
basically what they do is they have a
potential energy surface that looks like
this an energy surface where the atoms
are trapped like that
without them falling out it's so clumsy
i know where the
atoms are trapped in a little valley
and then by
basically changing the experimental
parameters you want to know all about it
read the paper what they do is they very
rapidly put it like that and trap those
atoms
in that particular state so what you've
now done is you've moved to a energy
distribution that looks like this what i
really want to get across is that they
haven't gone through zero they have not
got to zero kelvin that is still
vobotin in terms of the laws of
thermodynamics and quantum mechanics
it's not what they've done they've got a
negative temperature and you might
wonder
why i mentioned a laser earlier on well
the way a laser works is that it
effectively exploits a negative
temperature because this thing for
reasons i hope
are reasonably
clear now this is called a population
inversion and what happens is that
electrons which is what we're doing here
fall down from this level to this level
and they give out a photon and that's
that but you've basically engineered
negative temperature again for the
parents and i know for 60 symbols videos
there's quite a few of you
got to point out that there's a big
difference because this is this is i
guess we should have a technical
disclaimer at this point this is
effectively a non-equilibrium effect
what they've done here is in essence
equilibrium thermodynamics subtle
difference
is a negative temperature hot or cold
hot hot in the sense that you know how
do we think how do we determine whether
something's hot or cold well it's always
sort of relative to something else it's
hot in the sense that if you have a
normal temperature object and you bring
a negative temperature object heat will
flow this way just go with my goodness
okay don't talk to me just go with me
okay
show me what happens if the temperature
of that is absolute zero
thank you it can't be i know but there
we go now show me what happens
if that is
lukewarm
all right no
now
show me what happens if that is very hot
now
show me what happens if that is a
negative temperature it has it
you can't do it it's just you can't
because what you have to have is
effectively a temperature that's greater
than this
um the possible total amount of energy
this can have and
in this particular system you can't it
doesn't work for this system and it
doesn't work for so many systems because
what you have to do is to have a limit
to have an upper limit on the total
amount of energy you can have
it's it's really difficult to explain
brittany but you can it's it's this this
is where the analogy breaks down you
just can't it just doesn't work sorry